todos acuden a honrar esta estatua una
representación de Jesús conocida en
Xochimilco como el niñopa la familia
abad flores está a cargo de las fiestas
una ocasión muy esperada
esperamos siete años
en su casa los anfitriones reciben a sus
vecinos durante todo el día
el niñopa es una un niño del pueblo que
tiene más de 400 años de existencia y es
una un niño que ha venerado siempre
Xochimilco este se le atribuyen muchos
Milagros la gente tiene fe y confía
mucho en el niño la familia ha invertido
alrededor de 53 mil dólares los ahorros
de toda su vida en esta celebraciones
excepcional más de 500 personas están
invitadas a disfrutar de Las
especialidades de la posada atole y
tamales es
el chile verde y carne
al caer la noche el niñopa debe volver a
casa los participantes recrean la
peregrinación de María y José en busca
de una posada para descansar la
procesión se estructura según un
estricto ritual esa previsión que cuenta
de tres etapas que los chinelos que es
la parte de la fiesta del del Festival
del carnaval la parte de la gente que es
el tejido social y posteriormente la
parte de la imagen que es ahí donde se
consagra la fe donde se consagra El
Milagro porque mucha gente viene y le
pide algún favor al niño Los Chinelos
son también una caricatura de Los
Conquistadores españoles y sus fiestas
desmedidas la procesión está llena de
danza y fuegos artificiales en honor al
niño prodigio
es algo muy hermoso verlo son las las
creencias de nosotros que son muy muy
hermosas al sentirlo
una vez que llega todos rezan por última
vez al niño va por más Milagros antes de
volver a verlo al día siguiente para
otra posada
[Música]